yo quiero poder identificar de estos
tres números si son racionales o
irracionales y bueno esencialmente
recuerda que un número racional un
número racional x se me ocurre lo
podemos ver como una proporción o una
razón de dos números enteros m entre n
por ejemplo y bueno vamos a ver si estos
los de aquí los puedo expresar de esta
manera y si no son irracionales así que
déjame quitar esto de aquí ok y vamos a
trabajar con el primero que dice 9 más
la raíz de 45 ahora 99 claramente es un
número racional 9 lo podemos ver como 9
sobre 1 que ello lo que tú quieras pero
raíz de 45 como lo podemos ver bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
9 más la raíz de y en lugar de poner 45
voy a poner 9 por 5 9 por 5 ok la raíz
de 45 es exactamente lo mismo que 9 por
5 y bueno esto es lo mismo que tomarme 9
la raíz de 9 por la raíz de 5 estos son
propiedades de las raíces ahora raíz de
9 la raíz principal de nueve es 3
entonces esto lo podemos ver como nueve
más tres veces la raíz de 5 sin embargo
raíz de 5 no es un cuadrado perfecto por
lo tanto la raíz de 5 no la podemos
sacar de este radical y entonces la raíz
de 5 de hecho es la raíz de un número
primo y por lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado este es un número irracional
ahora date cuenta que si este de aquí es
un número irracional este de aquí es un
número racional tres veces un número de
racional sigue siendo un número racional
la multiplicación de un número racional
por un número racional me da un número
de racional y bueno a este número
irracional si le sumamos un número
nacional sigue siendo irracional todo
esto todo esto es un número irracional
un número racional más
racional por un número racional es
irracional todo por esta raíz de 5 así
que vamos a ponerlo esto es
sí o no de lujo ok ahora fijémonos en
este de aquí no tengo la raíz de 45
entre tres veces la raíz de cinco y lo
primero que se me ocurre es tomarme la
raíz de arriba y escribirla como la raíz
de 9 ok por la raíz de 5 la raíz de 9
por la raíz de 5 todo esto entre tres
veces la raíz de 5 ahora 9 por 5 45 pero
lo padre de esto y lo que quiero que
veas es que la raíz principal de 9
habíamos dicho que es 3 entonces esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 3 es la raíz
de 9 por la raíz de 5 ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre es de aquí que es tres
veces la raíz de cinco y que crees tres
veces la raíz de cinco entre tres veces
la raíz de cinco es un número entre sí
mismo y por lo tanto esto es lo mismo
que uno y uno es un número bastante
racional uno lo podemos ver como uno
sobre 13 sobre 39 sobre 9 o bueno en
este caso ahora podemos decir que uno lo
podemos ver
como tres veces las raíces se encuentra
tres veces la raíz de 5 entonces el 1
racional y esta expresión completa es un
número nacional de acción racional de
lujo ahora vamos con estar aquí tengo
tres veces la raíz de 9 pero bueno la
raíz de 9 su raíz principal es 3 y me
quedaría 3 por 3 lo cual por cierto es 9
y 9 es un número racional 9 lo podemos
ver como 9 sobre 1 como 18 sobre 227
sobre eso como tú lo quieras ver 9 es un
número bastante racional racional y qué
crees hemos acabado este problema